trouver il y a trente ans l'envié le cas
quitter le sénégal pour s'installer au
québec
il a rencontré sa femme une québécoise
avec qui il a eu quatre enfants dont sa
fille amy montréal occupe une place
importante dans la vie de mondial qui
m'a beaucoup marqué on sert là où j'ai
bâti ma vie professionnelle
si bien qu'il a tenu à rendre un hommage
particulier à la métropole
en 2012 gondiel et sa famille ont
commencé à bâtir un petit village au
sénégal avec ses 300 vaches avec mes
parents au sénégal par sa soixantaine
d'habitants ça c'est les enfants qui
semble à son chemin d'accès il ya pas de
pot les allées et même un nom officiel
depuis cette année et mon frère et moi
on a rappelé ce dès l'âge morère la fidh
gondiel revient du village et il reste
beaucoup de travail
on est en train de construire un village
qui permet aussi qui donne de l'emploi
puis aussi qui permet aux gens de se
revenir à leurs besoins en même temps
n'a pas encore l'électricité
on n'a pas encore de l'eau courante le
grand défi aujourd'hui est l'accès aux
soins de santé pour les villageois alors
gondiel et sa fille temps d'y remédier
avec l'aide de leur famille là bas moi
et ma fille on a un projet d'implanter
la barre en centre de santé un
dispensaire pour a les femmes qui sont
1,5
parce que dans ce secteur le taux de
mortalité maternelle et la mortalité
infantile et maternelle c'est un sujet
qui touche gondiel sa femme est décédée
en accouchant ici au québec en 2008
sa fille a posé la première pierre du
futur dispensaire fin juillet le centre
de santé en fait c'est vraiment notre
nouveau projet ce qu'on veut faire qu'en
fait c'est un centre de santé en or de
meneur mondial et zafy commence à
promouvoir le projet auprès des
montréalais en commençant par le maire
coderre
on va bien il se dit touché
c'est un beau clin d'oeil ce que je
trouve extraordinaire dans la proche
c'est ce sentiment de redonner et de
reconnaissance je veux montrer ça ça
vous démontre à quel point que cette
magnifique diversité culturelle qui
montréal cette diversité c'est des ponts
bâtis par ou insultant le maire à des
questions qu'est ce que tu fais avec les
nids-de-poule un cd et même des
suggestions de prades équipe de recul
non je n'ai le buzzer ni milieu les
revenus générés par l'élevage et
l'agriculture ne permettent pas aux
villageois de s'offrir des équipes de
sport mais gondiel et sa fille
réfléchissent à différents moyens pour
obtenir du financement pour un
dispensaire auprès notamment de tous
ceux qui sont intéressés par le projet
qu'ils viennent de montréal ou
d'ailleurs ici bas dans habillant radio
canada montréal